ちょっと待って
これやばくないか？
こちらです
ここら辺だね、温泉があるね
ここに行きましょう
行ってきます！
どこ超えなきゃいけないの、だって静岡スタートでしょ？
まさき：山梨から
山梨→群馬
これなんて書いてあるの？
”村上”この辺なんかわからないんだよ
村上っぽくない？点の位置的に
とりあえず村上に行く？
うん、ここに温泉があるんだよねこれ
ほら
この温泉行こ
というわけで今から我々は
えーっとダーツの旅ということで僕が適当に投げたマジックの場所が
村上という場所だったので
そこら辺近辺に今から向かいます
今8月の20日なんですけども
多分8月の20中くらい？
8月の20日は多分村上にいるので
とくに来てくださいとは言いませんが
います！
行くぞ！
行くぞ行くぞ
まずは東京方面に向かっております
まあ、後々なんでケガしたのかは分かると思うので
いやまじこっからだからね長いのは
はいというわけで引き続き行きましょう
はいというわけで今ですね八王子まで来ました
埼玉県の狭山に着きました
おおーやっと来たねー
はいというわけで今群馬まで来たんですけども
このまま突っ走って新潟まで行って
多分お昼くらいから動くよね？
多分お昼いっぱいはその
新潟県の村上市にいると思います
せっかくだからねなんかね新潟で色々
美味しい物とか
良い場所に行ったり
現地の人に会ったりしたいので
新潟の皆
待っててくれ